las últimas noticias serían que los tres
comandantes de las fuerzas armadas
habrían renunciado antes de que el nuevo
ministro de defensa pidiese su relevo la
razón serían las profundas discordancias
con el presidente jair bolsonaro hay que
recordar que ayer el ministro de defensa
defensa que salió fernando aseveró lo
dijo diciendo que intentó durante todo
su mandato que en las fuerzas armadas
pueda ser una institución de estado y no
de gobierno de hecho a lo largo de esos
dos años ha servido intentó mantenerse
alejado de la deriva autoritaria de la
deriva de derecha del presidente de jair
bolsonaro y participó es crítico también
cuando él
bolsonaro participó en las
manifestaciones a favor del cierre del
tribunal supremo- hay que decir que él
bolsonaro ha intentado politizar las
fuerzas armadas parece dicen los
bastidores que habría pedido tanto al
ministro de defensa que ha salido como
altos generales que apoyasen al gobierno
con
textos en sus redes sociales la
respuesta fue negativa la principal
piedra en el zapato de bolsonaro era el
jefe del comandante jefe del ejército
exxon con jon que varias veces dijo que
los militares no deberían estar en el
gobierno y que además estaba en
desacuerdo con la gestión de la pandemia
por parte de bolsonaro hay una parte
progresista de las fuerzas armadas que
defienden la democracia pero hay que
recordar que mañana se celebra el
aniversario del golpe militar que llevó
a la dictadura y de nuevo los bastidores
parece que forzara no quería un texto
por parte de las fuerzas armadas con más
entusiasmo y que el ejército la parte
más progresista se niega a hacer eso
valeria de tal como decía esto que está
sucediendo se suma a la renuncia de
varios ministros que dejaron sus cargos
hablábamos del canciller del ministro de
defensa entre otros
cuales cómo definirías al escenario
político de brasil en estos momentos
valeria nos queda poquito tiempo
lamentablemente
con con turba todo para algunos muestra
la debilidad de bolsonaro cuya
popularidad está en caída libre por la
gestión de la pandemia pero también por
el fin del subsidio especial a los
desempleados que tal vez se reanude en
abril
bolsonaro necesita del apoyo del
centrado del grupo de diez partidos que
funcionan como bisagra en el sistema
político brasileño entre otras cosas
porque hay más de 60 peticiones de
impeachment contra el el mundo
empresarial y financiera sería causado
de la deriva autoritaria del presidente
porque la imagen de brasil en el
exterior es cada vez peor